today june 1st kicks off our culture's
holiest and most sacred month a month
which as it has been decreed by every
fortune 500 corporation including the
fortune 500 corporation known as the us
government must be set aside to
celebrate several of the deadliest sins
in particular pride it is a pride month
of course we we used to have pride
parades which would you know hope which
would happen on certain days you'd have
like a pride event
but that wasn't enough so they came up
with pride day and that wasn't enough so
they declared pride week and that wasn't
enough so then we had pride month
but that also was not enough which is
why pride month is but one occasion on
the calendar set aside for the noble
royalty in the lgbt kingdom there are
many other days as well indeed every
month features at least one holy day of
lgbt observation the bite administration
kicked things off today by unfurling a
pride flag over the u.s embassy in
vatican city they still don't have
enough pride to do the same thing over
our embassies in say saudi arabia or
pakistan
well that's not completely true actually
the u.s embassy in pakistan did in fact
hold a pride event back in 2011 under
obama
but the muslim population in the country
protested back in 2011 calling the event
quote cultural terrorism and condemning
the lgbt community as quote and i'm
quoting a curse of society and social
garbage
the us embassy in pakistan has been a
little less vocal about gay pride ever
since but here at home the government is
loud and proud and brave biden issued a
proclamation today declaring quote
this month we celebrate generations of
lgbtqi plus people who have fought to
make the possibilities of our nation
real for every american he then veered
into even more fantasy claiming
today the rights of lgbtqi plus
americans are under relentless attack
members of the lgbtqi plus community
especially people of color and trans
people continue to face discrimination
and cruel persistent efforts to
undermine their human rights an
onslaught of dangerous anti-lgbtqi plus
legislation has been introduced and
passed in states across the country
targeting transgender children and their
parents and interfering with their
access to health care these
unconscionable attacks have left
countless
lgbtqi plus families in fear and pain
we keep hearing about anti-lgbt
legislation
yeah nobody ever provides an example of
such legislation all they can do is
speak generally about it or else um
invent specific bills you know ones that
they invent like the don't say gay bill
which doesn't actually exist
but never do they point to the actual
language of an actual piece of
legislation in an actual american state
to prove that there is anti-lgbt
conspiracy
you'll notice that they never they never
quote any of these bills directly
and that's because there is no such
conspiracy lgbt people have uh no
persecution they face no persecution in
this country uh they face the opposite
of persecution in fact the modern
american lgbt person if he conforms
ideologically to the left-wing doctrines
of the day which is always the qualifier
here but if he does
then he will be by far and away the most
privileged sort of american to ever
exist
because there's never been a group as
relentlessly coddled pampered
complimented
elevated
fond over and supported as lgbt people
in modern america
and yet
leftism anchors itself on the victim
hierarchy which means that it must
always be fighting against this
imaginary victimization but it can never
succeed in actually stopping the
victimization or even improving the
situation slightly
can't do that
this is one of the great leftist ironies
the whole thing falls apart if they ever
admit that they've succeeded in doing
any of the things they're supposedly
trying to do if they say well you know
we fought to make lgbt people more
accepted in society and clearly we
succeeded so good for us
if they do that then they'll have
nothing left to do or say and
they'll watch themselves evaporate into
vapor
so they must always fight for this
acceptance and yet by their own telling
continually lose
they will become impotent if they don't
pretend that they are impotent it's a
very
confused situation
and perhaps that's what this month ought
to be called instead actually confusion
month not pride month
and it is that
confusion
which will be exposed tonight with the
premiere finally of our film was a woman
we held off releasing a film so that we
could coincide its premiere with the
start of pride month which is just the
sort of petty and trolling move that
you've come to expect and love from me
uh or at least expect anyway i don't
know about love
there's nothing petty about the film
though despite its origins the truth is
that you know the film
did begin with a tweet four years ago i
put out the question
out into the world on twitter
what is a woman because it occurred to
me that the statement i identify as a
woman
doesn't mean anything if the person
making the statement or the people
telling us to take the statement
seriously aren't able to define the
thing that the person is identifying as
so
i posed the question to the left they
didn't answer so i kept tweeting it uh
and they didn't answer that so i wrote
articles about it i gave speeches about
it i talked about it on my show
and still i couldn't get an answer and i
had it that point a choice
one option was simply to let it go but i
can't let anything go and so i took the
second option which is
this film
when we set out to ask this question and
um in the process explore the darkest
depths of gender ideology
the truth is that i didn't know
you know exactly what would happen
all i knew is that if we're making a
film out of this
i didn't want we didn't want it to be
just your standard right-wing
documentary we're not interested in
bringing a bunch of people i agree with
into a room asking them questions just
so they could give me an answer that i
could have said myself and then slap a
bunch of narration on top of it
if that's how we were going to approach
the film we may as well not approach it
at all
we knew that we had to go out and put
ourselves into the middle of the madness
we had to actually pursue answers we had
to talk to people we don't already agree
with we had to take some risks perhaps
even put ourselves in some unsafe
situations here and there um that's the
only way to tell this story and if we
were gonna get answers
it was the only way to get them
and our journey took us all over the
country and behind beyond which you'll
see tonight as you've heard we even went
to africa deep into kenya down into the
uh into the bush to speak to the messiah
tribe and our reason for talking to the
messiah tribe was was really threefold
one we wanted to test the leftist claim
that the gender binary is a western
construct
you can't get more
non-western than the messiah tribe and
if the man-woman distinction is a
western social construct which is what
the left says they say that the idea
that you know men have penises women
have giants that's a social cut it's
like a western
colonialist idea that's what they said
and if that's the case then surely the
messiah tribe will have an entirely
different way of thinking about gender
and two if it turns out that the maasai
actually do believe that sex is binary
then we wanted to see what it would be
like to try to explain
these progressive ideas about gender to
people who have no frame of reference
for them
sometimes that's the best way to find
out if an idea is totally incoherent
and three we went because we thought it
would be really funny
that's you know actually that might be
the first reason and all the other ones
but still those are the reasons how did
it all work out
well i have a short clip of that
exchange actually which i'm finally
allowed to play for you and we'll do
that right now check it out
what if a man decides that his his
gender identity
is
and a man has its own duty and a lady
cannot duty the duty of a man and a man
cannot do a duty of a woman
can a man
become a woman
kill them allah
no no it looked like to if you want to
become a lady but your man
you have something wrong
something wrong in your family from the
wrong in you
what about if someone was non-binary
come again
non-binary
do you know
like someone is
you're not a woman you're not a man
yeah someone's like someone is neither
there's something else is that
it
one purpose
he's saying we have never seen things
like those for a man he has a penis for
a woman he has a vagina so we know this
is a lady this is a man what if it's a
woman with a what if it's a woman with a
penis
but
[Laughter]
is transphobia there is just shocking
and there's much more where that came
from but as you can see from that
snippet um it is gender ideology not the
gender binary which is a western
construct
the tribesmen say that transgender
people have something wrong in their
heads and their families
uh
that's what they said you know
don't shoot the messenger
they get kicked off youtube for talking
like that if they had youtube or the
internet or the electricity
they'd get doxxed for such talk if they
had fixed addresses and weren't nomadic
they'd get fired from their jobs if they
had jobs but they have none of those
things they exist outside the modern
western bubble completely and it's a
very different world out there as we
discovered we discovered much more in
our film and in keeping with pride month
i can say that um i'm very proud of the
film we gave a year of our lives to this
project at the end of it all i think i
can say that it was worth it
and you could see for yourself but you
have to be a daily wire member so go to
whatiswoman.com get ready for the
premiere tonight and um and the final
thing i'll say is to the leftists who
are already quite upset about this film
and they've been trying to d-platform me
and get me kicked off of everything and
i don't know if they'll succeed in doing
that or not
um and they're doing all this even
though they haven't even seen the film
yet
but to them all i can say is you should
have just responded to my tweet
i gave you a chance to answer my
question
you ignored me
and now look at what you've done
this is all your fault
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content